hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
so today I wanted to talk about
something special I believe I'm making
advancements in my life
what I want to do in my life is read
more oh me too
I haven't read a fictional book in about
four years that's [ __ ] up it's a lot
of self-help books personal development
playboy perfect ten occasionally every
the entertainment articles on Yahoo
Report I decided to type in some channel
on Google called cinema sins and cinema
sins as you guys know is one of my
favorite YouTube channels I found out
that Jeremy Scott one of the co-creators
of cinema sins has put together a book
called the Abel's I found it on Amazon
it comes out May 1st I'm very interested
in reading this one though for very
specific reasons and I'm gonna review
the book - I'm making a video about it
because I thought it'd be cool if a lot
of you guys read it - went to your local
library or bought it and then when I
review it I could go into spoilers and
stuff here's the description for you
guys all right read along I did have
fantastic hearing mostly by virtue of
being blind but that couldn't actually
mean that he's trying to tell me I have
superpowers right because that would be
ridiculous
it wasn't the sexist aapki expected
philip Salinger's dad has told them he's
a custodian a guardian and it's
genetically inherited powers telekinesis
it'll learn to move objects with his
mind excited to begin superhero high
school - they discovered he's assigned
to a special ed class for disabled and
powered kids he suddenly feels like an
outsider bully threatened and betrayed
Phillip struggles even as he and his
friends calling themselves the Abel's
find ways to maximize their powers to
overcome their disabilities and are the
first to identify the growing evil
threatening humanity as vaio custodians
disappear and the custodian leadership
is mirrored and indecision mired and
then to see this is why I have to read
more a mysterious and powerful figure
taunts Phillip and the enemy is poised
to strikes right but what if the next
one who does all the multi gifted
custodian predicted
come is one of the evils oh yeah oh he
probably will be he probably he's
probably the chosen won't probably see
this character more likely than not mmm
I hope so and already a widely popular
storytellers co-creator and narrator of
cinemasins a youtube channel that has
amassed more than 3.8 million
subscribers in under two years Wow in
two years we are almost at a hundred
thousand subscribers they are any other
point eight million not moving along no
we're we're not moving as fast as we
could you got a ready I got to write a
book called the capables does sound cool
like before I get into some of my
opinions on this I was doing some
research I went all out with this one
their biggest thing on cinemasins is
everything wrong with the cinemasins
list these are 23 comic book movies that
they have done everything wrong with the
amazing spider-man 2
The Avengers the Dark Knight Rogers the
Tuck night Iron Man Iron Man - Green
Lantern Superman return x-men x-men -
x-men you die they spend the last end
kick-ass that any ins daredevil Iron Man
3 Thor Man of Steel Batman in Rubin 3
all good Captain America the First
Avenger Thor the dark world spider-man
spider-man 2 well Jeremy since you can
find everything wrong with these
superhero movies I wanted to challenge
you to see how your opinions have
changed your writing how's it made hands
better if you can pick apart what's
wrong with these can you orchestrate a
story that doesn't have any of those
pitfalls because most of these comic
book movies are superhero stories and
this is very superhero inspired
obviously is it's about superheroes
it'll be interesting to me be like
alright this guy could point out a lot
of things wrong with superhero stories
let's see if he knows how to tell one
himself can he walk the walk I'm
guessing you probably can because you
know book is a realm where yeah I'm get
away with a lot more stuff and take your
time to explain things it sounds really
interesting to me to like this sounds
like a book I could actually read yeah
I'm interested to read this because I
like the the capsule is sort of like
here's the gist of the book but now I
want to know what makes it
unique to Jeremy what James vision
brings to this sort of arena it's just
the fact that he's one of the
co-creators of cinemasins that yeah that
I have to read this book well yeah and
it's cool to see the crossover start to
happen of like you know people talking
about existing stuff on YouTube and then
going out and complete it there's
actually very inspiring yeah you know
like because I know a lot of people who
do reviews including us we do this to
hopefully one day be able to create our
own material to it's really inspiring to
see someone go a youtuber who started
off with opinions and now is going out
there and showing his creativity yeah
one does a cool wait you know cuz you
can keep what you love and what makes
you a fan intact and then also take that
into your own hands engage with it and
as far as the content goes it sort of
reminds me like sky high and x-men you
know like x-men had the school of
superheroes and sky high was really
inspired by all these colonies and so
gonna let just go ahead like this seems
like a darker version of sky high to me
he's like a really bloody sky because I
haven't seen sky high but basically it's
a school for superheroes where they get
taken on a Magic School Bus over to
there when it comes to sky high they
have these characters that are heroes or
sidekicks yeah and that's what it kind
of reminds me of because they're talking
about like these are special children
they are disabled because sky high
doesn't focus on the sidekicks it
focuses on the heroes yeah you know the
psychics are characters in there some of
them are main characters but the heroes
are the main focus yeah so this is cool
to see like he's really focusing on the
underdogs of the story yeah all the
heroes and the x-men stories that you
don't really hear about if this sort of
like prophesied character like the one
who does all I think it's cool if I'm
reading this correctly and that's not
like the focal character I think that's
actually kind of cool to have a side
character be sort of off in the distance
who has all these powers because we're
so used to seeing like the protagonist
is the one who can do everything mm-hmm
you know and it'd be kind of cool to see
that character described but not driving
the story yeah so I hope I'm reading
that kind of like a supporting role like
it kind of reminds me of that
you're one where it's like Bruce Wayne
and Batman are in it but the main focus
is Commissioner Gordon yeah it's like I
love stuff like that Gordon's not like a
psychic like it would be cool and I'm
sure if somebody's done it but like to
read a Batman story from Robins point of
view or something that they say this
character is he's blind and that's why
it has fantastic hearing then I was
thinking like oh maybe he has dairy a
little kind of powers and stuff but then
he was saying the as telekinesis it's
very comp because you got like people
like Jean Grey you got Magneto you got I
imagine it could be a very dark tale I
don't imagine it it's like something
that's pg-13 down I think this could be
something very dark you know comes out
May first and that's the same time as
Avengers the launch date on that one in
animus since it makes me wonder like it
could be sort of young adult E or it
could be dark and heavy I'm interested
to see I'm interested to find that they
talk about the Able's like coming
together and increase their powers and
then they're the ones who are like yo we
know about evil what about you guys the
growing evil it's just you know like the
Dementors or Bouldin working when they
said that in the description
yeah that's growing shadow that follows
him and it sounds like you know that
this main character Phillip is Harry
Potter or [ __ ] neo and I imagine his
powers to sort of be like neo in Matrix
Revolutions
cuz he went blind together I'm sorry you
cannot big matrix kick yeah that but
just saw that he goes blind but he's
able to like see the program still in
the real world because neo can also like
move stuff he's telekinetic in a lot of
ways there's just a lot of omage here
and that that's okay like it doesn't
have to be 100% original because like
the powers are talking about don't sound
that or they're not original we've seen
them before but it's the context of the
world that they're putting in and that
can make it original well yeah it said
it's that sort of blend of familiarity
and new stuff it's like this guy clearly
knows all the tropes and trappings of
these kinds of comic book and and sort
of action sci-fi stories and I'm
interested to see what the balance is
between like you know the familiar
framework and the cool new ideas to
color it in with yeah I hope this stays
like a good character driven story I
hope it does
become you know like this is very cliche
way as it can play out for the Able's
coming together they hear about the bad
guy then it's like good versus bad and
our main character saves the day yeah
like I think it could be a very unique
dark tale like I'm drawing the stories
like Watchmen and stuff where it's a
different take on the superhero genre
yeah they're focusing on the special ed
kids the interesting part about that is
that when you watch a hero you want to
be that hero but when you watch like
someone like this does have an underdog
you relate to that I feel that I could
like really to a lot like there are
things in my life that I've been
diagnosed with that if I didn't put such
focus on the fact that I've been
diagnosed and instead just work on
myself and the solutions more for the
past few years I'd be in a much better
place I'd be at a much bigger potential
that's what I like about this is that
they're disabled but disabled people are
coming together to overcome their
disabilities yeah there's no interesting
power like they have to help each other
you know yeah that's cool it's not just
like you got cool power you got cool
power now let's work together yeah it's
like let's overcome these disabilities
together yeah it's like we each have
sort of an extraordinary strength
durability that almost comes as directly
contrasting you know my disability and
together we make like a perfect whole
absolutely well anyway guys yeah we were
gonna be reading this book so I thought
it'd be cool to put it out there that
way when I do a book review although
hopefully some of you have read that
look out in May May May first remember
Avengers same time evils read it during
the Avengers I hear Jeremy Scott doesn't
rewatch the movies he just goes into the
theater and he's out loud saying that
here's what's wrong with it
you're just wrong with it this was wrong
with that and he walks out he remembers
everything and hence he's been invited
to so many privates great anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects oh you're
not a lot of smoke cigarettes with a
baseball field
go [ __ ] yourself corn three domes but
scratch up Jerry has a playlist on this
channel called reasons to Jerry reasons
to check out some of
reviews and you can follow us on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook the
ultimate social networks bit Facebook
Instagram Twitter let's talk about some
other video and glove my other acronym
is pix X P Y X porno calm you porn calm
xvideos calm good if I ever need to send
you porn for Christmas I'll know where
to go I have to wait till Christmas